our planning committee members are so
excited by the enthusiasm that we
received throughout the community for
coming up with the conference with the
largest the longest title ever welcome
to responding to resurgent HIV STI
incidents among MSM in Connecticut
effective HIV prevention interventions
for gay men I will be your master of
ceremonies time diva Oprah all of those
different things whatever you want to
call me for the day you know I started
doing this work in 1996 when I worked in
Ohio at AIDS volunteers of Cincinnati as
their first gay youth educator I'm
shocked that we're here today talking
about some of the same things that we
were talking about in 1996 but today is
an opportunity for us to come together
as an hiv/aids community to make a
difference today is the chance to have a
call to action to have a impact on what
is happening in the hiv/aids community
specifically with regard to increases
among men who sex with men and
particularly young gay and bisexual men
of color I'm so excited that we have
this partnership between the Department
of Public Health Sarah and karke it's
been an incredible journey I want to
acknowledge the planning committee
members Gina D'Angelo from dph Chris and
racin from dph roberto cruz was an
intern formerly an intern at dph lee
evans from sarah wilson palacios from
ceará lisa eaten from Sarah Sean Lang
from karke who unfortunately could not
be here today because she's at another
research summit up in Toronto leave
anybody else out from that committee I
think
so Sarah is involved in this because we
really believe in the importance of
taking scientific findings and getting
those findings out into community
practice the committee has been very
thoughtful and how we put together the
agenda today where you will hear from
some of the science around what's
happening in the community you'll hear
the science behind some effective
behavioral interventions and then oh ye
or how those interventions are actually
being implemented successfully by some
of our partners in our neighboring state
I want to briefly mention a project that
we have at syrah called the community
research partnership program this is a
partnership between sarah affiliated
scientist and a community partnering
agency there are several programs that
are funded throughout the state some of
you are very familiar with the program
one recently that got started is with
the Hartford gay and lesbian health
collective and the Institute for
community research and the Connecticut
trans advocacy coalition and chain that
is working to understand the needs of
trans the transgender population in
Hartford and to sort of enumerate that
category another one is with AIDS
Project new haven in which Ted white an
associate research scientist at the Yale
School of Public Health is working with
Chris Cole and his team from a pH to
actually go out into gay bars in New
Haven and do testing around HIV and
sexually transmitted infections to try
to identify people that are unaware of
their status and link them with care
that project is going to be starting
this summer hopefully it's my pleasure
to introduce the section chief for the
department of public health aids and
chronic diseases division Chris and
Jason
um thank you li fen good morning
everybody and on behalf of the
Department of Public Health I just want
to thank all of you for showing up for
this and I think you know initially we
really estimated really good how many
people are going to come maybe 75 80 you
know something like that and to have 200
people to show up and talk about HIV
prevention for gay men and other MSM and
I probably just say gay men just to stay
within leaves time frames here but do
you know to have you know about 200
people show up to kind of talk about and
focus on HIV prevention in Connecticut
related to gay men is just it's just a
wonderful thing and I'm so glad the ER
all here today and really hope that this
is a start not a start I mean because
we've already started their stuff
happening but we really want to see more
and we need to do more and that's what
the data is telling us you know and
thank you leave for thinking all the
planning committee I was going to do all
that stuff too but but he already did it
so I'm not going to i'm not going to
continue you know one of the main
reasons for this conference of course is
the continuing rate of HIV infection
among MSM that we're seeing in
connecticut and nationally too and also
the the rate of syphilis in Connecticut
you know i started i started working at
the department of public health in 1990
and i worked in the STD program
investigating syphilis cases and you
know as a young gay man and I was doing
partner notification for HIV and
syphilis cases and stuff and as a young
gay man getting into the HIV prevention
field I was really hoping to work with
you know gay men at high risk for HIV
and when it came to syphilis we really
didn't see on HIV cases among MSM and
you know that was a good thing so to see
it now completely flip-flopped the other
way I mean all the kids we had tons of
cases and it was all basically
heterosexual related to drug use a lot
of crack use and stuff like that and to
see it completely reverse we're
basically none of the cases are you know
there's no heterosexual cases basically
they're all basically MSM cases and
about a third of those cases are HIV
positive you know it's really scary and
it really kind of is a call to action
for us to do something you know one
thing I wanted to talk about to and kind
of was asked to talk about is the name
of this conference and I see we've you
know we've got this really nice long
very sort of dry name to the conference
today but it but it's very it's safe in
it in it you know I don't know if I saw
this originally if I how excited I would
have been about this conference but with
this conference name changing this
conference name change that we had you
know the original name you know one
actually part of this conference to you
know really what it what it came from is
a fact that a lot of providers and I had
sort of anecdotal conversations with
people about you know so why isn't your
agency you know why aren't you still
doing stuff with gay men you know what
happened it kind of fell off the radar
and a lot of people say well you know
we're just not sure what to do you know
we're not sure how we'd address it it's
things are different today it's the
internet and we're not sure how to
connect with that and you know at the
same time you know kind of case managers
we're seeing you know more MSM showing
up and continuing to show up but people
on the prevention side it was like we're
just not sure what to do you know and
people are almost in a sense afraid to
apply for funding for MSM in it you know
because we didn't know what we're going
to do with it so you know me I wasn't as
involved in the the conference planning
as Gina D'Angelo was but she kind of
would come back and fill me in and I'd
see the emails and stuff like that and
one day she came back and she was like
she's like well they work it on titles
and she's like they're talking about him
and some of them are a little sexually
explicit you know and I was like oh no I
said no no no I said if we are involved
in this we're not going to have a crazy
sexually explicit title all right I said
if they want to do that they can go
ahead I was like but we're not putting
dph his name on that because I just
don't want to go there right now I was
still enacting section chief to you know
so you know so fine so I kind of just
you know in the back of my mind I was
like what do they think you know what
are the names i was creating all these
ones and i'm not going to say them out
loud what what it might have been so so
finally i get this thing and it's like
here's the title gay men what was it
what can you do with what yeah gay men
what can we do with them and i thought i
was like oh that's it okay you know when
I in my gut I said this is exactly this
is exactly what people are saying this
is what the providers are saying what do
we do you know what I mean and on the
one hand they're sort of the kitschy
what do you do with them you know but on
the other hand there was a sort of like
deep kind of like what do we do with
them you know what do we do and it's out
of concern and love you know and I know
that there were some people that were
offended by that title and it hurt me to
the core I understand I understand what
you were saying but it was really very
you know deep hurt because you know this
evolved from a group of gay men and very
gay friendly people with true concern
and love for the gay community in
Connecticut and you know really wanted
to push the agenda on that so for one I
apologize to anyone who was offended for
the original title of the conference and
thank you for the feedback that you gave
us but to I want to assure you that we
never intended to you know to some of
the things that people were saying well
you know what put him on an island put
him here put him there it was never
there I hear what you're saying but that
was not the case so you know I just we
just really wanted to make that clear
and we're very sorry for anybody that
that was offended by the original title
but it truly truly did come from the
true sentiments in our little HIV
prevention world that we were hearing
you know and I think once it got shut
out to the broader community that aren't
necessarily involved in HIV prevention
every day you know sort of that what are
you going to do with them what the hell
does that mean you know that that kind
of reaction we were like oh man okay now
we see but but that really wasn't our
attention but we did listen and we did
change the title to this and you know I
also wonder if we would have had such a
great turnout if we didn't start with
that title that got everybody talking
about it you know so so we flip flopped
on the title but so glad in some ways
that we did start with that one to see
such a reaction and get people actually
talking again about HIV prevention with
MSM so so that's I think my five minutes
are up but I think leaf took more than
five minutes anyways but um I'm going to
turn it over now to you know feels like
old you know old times here in some ways
you know about in 1989 I was finishing
up at UConn and you know I don't know I
was like 22 or something like that and i
went to AIDS Project Hartford to do my
internship and there were two people
working there one was Patti ruot who is
the executive director at the time and
the other one was John murs and he was
the assistant
director and he was my supervisor from
my little internship you know and one
thing he asked me to do one day when I
went in there he brought me to this room
they had and he's like oh here's all
these papers I'd like you to just
collate these so I was like okay and I'm
like what the hell does collate maybe
hahaha yeah today I do know what it
means but I felt so stupid you know and
I remember it to this day but it's my
pleasure to introduce John MERS he's the
executive director of the Connecticut
AIDS Reese court raids resource
coalition where Sean Lang works and you
know they do amazing work and you know
Sean Lang's work is really i think you
know in karks work is really a huge
reason why we've been able to maintain
our funding for HIV AIDS in Connecticut
you know and they really just thank them
for the for the efforts that they do to
keep funding going for all the services
that they that they provide related to
housing and other things in Connecticut
and please help me welcome John Mars
well thank you good morning some of you
obviously don't know me good morning
that's more like it yes I am John murs
I'm the director of the Connecticut aids
Resource coalition you never see me out
because Sean lying and I arm-wrestle to
see who gets to go to these exciting
event and she's stronger than I am and
she always wins if she were here she
would say you need to stay involved and
get involved in the AIDS life campaign
it's only because of your voices and
you're going to the capital and you're
speaking to your legislators that we did
not incur such large cuts as other
social service agencies and fields so
please join karke it's very important
that we're able to show legislators the
the long list of our members become
involved in aids life campaign
participate in our events and we'll be
able to stay funded so I'm doing
commercials this morning that's my role
you'll see on the Dyess is a age chair
it is a visual representation that
we need to stay involved we need to
re-engage those who have fallen away we
have information both in English and in
Spanish what's really exciting about
this chair is that it came from a group
who got together Chris Cole from H
project New Haven pulled a group
together and said we've got to do
something we've got to do something and
out of it from the collective energy of
the group came the a chair Daryl
Decker's in the room from concerned
citizens for Humanity he made sure that
they were produced these can be rented
up to i think what do we have over a
hundred of these for your events each
project New Haven karke we have a couple
chairs if you just want one to symbolize
it at an event we can arrange to get
that to you so please use that it's
important that we get together and that
we collaborate and that their synergy so
I'm very excited to be one of the
co-sponsors of today and it's great to
see all of you it's like gold Home Week
so um we're going to send Shawn out of
the country more often so I can get to
see y'all